hallo leute heute werden wir euch einige
vokabeln rund um das thema kleidung
vorstellen
oder wie man auch sagt die klamotten
wisst ihr wie man die einzelnen teile
nennt dann schaut mal her
los geht's die jacke die jacke der
mantel die mäntel die regenjacke die
regenjacken die jeansjacke
die jeans jacken die cordjacke die
cordjacke die mütze die mützen
der hut die hüte der schal
die schals der handschuh die handschuhe
der stiefel die stiefel
[Musik]
die sandale
die sandale der show die schuhe die
socke die socken die hose die hosen die
jogginghose die jogginghosen
[Musik]
das t shirt die t shirts das hemmt die
hände
das jackett die jacketts
die krawatte die krawatten
[Musik]
der anzug die anzüge die strickjacke
die strickjacke der pullover die
pullover der kapuzenpullover die
kapuzenpullover eine jacke zwei jacken
ein mantel zwei menschen in dieser
episode kommen viele vokabeln vor bei
denen es nicht so einfach ist zu wissen
wie die plattform gebildet wird probiert
doch mal unsere app sie länger aus dort
haben wir einen plural trainer mit eme
die plattform von vielen weiteren lernen
könnt nun zeigen wir euch noch einige
sätze die man nutzen kann wenn man
kleidung beschreiben möchte warum macht
mit sich so schick
das steht der gutmensch
du hast dann shirt falsch rum an mach
doch mal die jacke zu
das ist hier zu klein
das ist dir zu groß
das steht hier nicht so gut
die farbe kann mich gut tragen
die hose ist zu kurz die hose passt
match nicht die schuhe sind mit zu klein
die jacke ist für den frühling viel zu
warm
die farbe passt gut zum match augenfarbe
die farbe passt gut zu mit farbe mit
knöpft sich das hemd zu trägst du den
anzug ohne krawatte mit bindet sich die
krawatte
[Musik]
mit schlägt sich den schal um mit zieht
eine mütze auf oder zwei oder drei
mit sie die jacke an
diese schuhe sind unbequem
der pullover
[Musik]
dieser stoff ist schön weich
die farbe ist zu grell mit streckt
socken in den sandalen wie ein deutscher
[Musik]
heute ist es ziemlich kalt draußen mit
zieht sich lieber warm an
so das war
ich hoffe ihr konntet heute viele
weitere vokabeln rund um das thema
kleidung lernen und wenn ihr jetzt noch
weiter die plattform trainieren volt
probiert mal unsere apps i länger aus
bis bald
[Musik]
mit streckt socken in den sandalen wie
ein deutscher
[Musik]